hi guys this is uccle and today we are
going to discuss about Amazon redshift
which is one of the data warehouse
service on the AWS but before starting
up with the Amazon redshift I would
request you guys to subscribe our
channel you can find the link just below
this video at the right side so let's
begin with Amazon redshift and let's see
what we have for today's session so
what's in it for you today we see what
is AWS now why we require Amazon
redshift what do we mean by Amazon
redshift the advantages of Amazon
redshift the architecture of Amazon
redshift some of the additional concepts
associated with the redshift and the
companies that are using the Amazon
redshift and finally will cover up a1
demo which will show you the practical
example that how you can actually use
the redshift service now what is AWS as
we know that AWS stands for Amazon Web
service it's one of the largest cloud
providers in the market and it's
basically a secure cloud service
platform provided from the Amazon also
on the AWS you can create and deploy the
applications using the airplay service
along with that you can access the
services provided by the AWS over the
public network that is over the internet
they are accessible plus you pay only
whatever the service you use for now
let's understand why we require Amazon
redshift so earlier before Amazon
redshift what used to happen that the
people used to or the developers used to
fetch the data from the data warehouse
so data warehouse is basically a
terminology which is basically
represents the collection of the data so
a repository where the data is stored is
generally called as a data warehouse now
fetching data from the data warehouse
was a complicated task because might be
a possibility that the developer is
located at a different geography and the
data data warehouses at a different
location and probably there is not that
much network connectivity or some
networking challenges Internet
connectivity challenges security
challenges might be and a lot of
maintenance was required
to manage the data warehouses so what
were the cons of the traditional data
warehouse services it was time consuming
to download or get the data from the
data warehouse maintenance cost was high
and there was the possibility of loss of
information in between the downloading
of the data and the data rigidity was an
issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was basically solved
with the introduction of Amazon redshift
over the cloud platform now we see that
Amazon redshift has solved traditional
data warehouse problems that the
developers were facing but how what is
Amazon redshift actually is so what is
Amazon redshift it is one of the
services over the AWS Amazon Web
Services which is called as a data
warehouse service so Amazon redshift is
a cloud-based service or a data
warehouse service that is primarily used
for collecting and storing the large
chunk of data so it also helps you to
get or extract the data analyze the data
using some of the BI tools so business
intelligence tools you can use and get
the data from the redshift and process
stack and hence it simplifies the
process of handling the large-scale data
sets so this is the symbol for the
Amazon redshift over the AWS
now let's discuss about one of the use
case so DNA is basically a
telecommunication company and they were
facing an issue with managing their
website and also the Amazon s3 data
which led down to slow process of their
applications now how could they overcome
this problem let's say that so they
overcome this issue by using the Amazon
redshift and all the company noticed
that there was a 52% increase in the
application performance now did you know
that Amazon redshift is basically cost
less to operate than any other cloud
data warehouse service available on the
cloud computing platforms and also the
performance of an Amazon redshift is the
fastest data warehouse we can say that
that is available as of now so in both
cases one is that it saves the cost as
compared to the traditional data
warehouses and also the performance of
this redshift service or a data where of
service the fastest available on the
cloud platforms and more than 15,000
customers primarily presently
they are using the Amazon redshift
service now let's understand some of the
advantages of Amazon redshift first of
all as we saw that it is one of the
fastest available data warehouse service
so it has the high performance second is
it is a low cost service so you can have
large scale of data warehouse order
databases combined in a data warehouse
at a very low cost so whatever you use
you pay for that only scalability now in
case if you wanted to increase the nodes
of the databases in your redshift you
can actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so the scalability is
again one of the advantage of the Amazon
redshift availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create a whenever you
access redshift you create a clusters in
the redshift and the clusters are
created in D you can define a specific
virtual private cloud for your cluster
and you can create your own security
groups and attach it to your cluster so
you can design the security parameters
based on your requirement and you can
get your data warehouse or the data
items a secured place
flexibility and you can remove the
clusters you can create under clusters
if you are deleting a cluster you can
take a snapshot of it and you can move
those snapshots to different regions so
that much flexibility is available on
the AIDA players for the service and the
other advantage is that it is basically
a very simple way to do a database
migration so if you are planning that
wanted to migrate your databases from
the traditional data center over the
cloud on the redshift it is basically a
very simple to do er database migration
you can have some of the inbuilt tools
available on the AWS access you can
connect them with your traditional data
center and get that data migrated
directly to the redshift now let's
understand the architecture of the
Amazon redshift so architecture of an
Amazon redshift is basically it combines
of a cluster and that we call it as a
data warehouse cluster in this picture
you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
presentation of Amazon redshift so it
has some of the compute nodes which does
the data processing and a leader node
which gives the instructions to these
compute nodes and also the leader node
basically manages the client
applications that require the data from
the redshift so let's understand about
the components of the redshift the
client application of Amazon redshift
basically interact with the leader node
using JDBC or the ODBC now what is JDBC
it's a java database connectivity and
the ODBC stands for open database
connectivity the Amazon redshift service
using a JDBC connector can monitor the
connections from the other client
applications so the leader node can
actually have a check on the client
applications using the JDBC connections
whereas the ODBC allows a leader node to
have a direct interaction or to have a
live interaction with the Amazon
redshift so ODBC allows a user to
interact with live data of Amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct access of the applications as
well as the leader node can get the
information from the compute nodes now
what are these compute nodes these are
basically is kind of a databases which
does the processing so Amazon redshift
has a set of computing resources which
we call it as a nodes and the nodes when
they are combined together they are
called it as a clusters now a cluster a
set of computing resources which are
called as nodes and this gathers into a
group which we call it as a data
warehouse cluster so you can have a
computed starting from 1 to n number of
nodes and that's why we call that the
redshift is a scalable service because
we can scale up the compute nodes
whenever we require now the data
warehouse clustered or the each cluster
has one or more databases in the form of
a nodes now what is a leader node this
node basically manages the interaction
between the client application and the
compute node so it acts as a bridge
between the client application and the
compute nodes also it analyzes and
developed designs in order to carry out
any kind of a database operations so
leader node basically sends out the
instructions to the compute nodes
basically perform or execute that
instruction and give that output to the
leader node so
that is what we are going to see in the
next slide that the leader nolde runs
the program and assigned the code to
individual compute nodes and the compute
nodes execute the program and share the
result back to the leader node for the
final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client at application
for analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slaves is allotted
with specific memory space or you can
say a storage space where the data is
processed these note slices works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these nodes lasers work in
a parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with Amazon redshift is there
are two additional concepts associated
with the red shirt one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from the columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples are
mentioned here so below examples show
how database tables store record into
disk block by row so here you can see
that if we wanted to pull out some kind
of an information based on the city
address age we can basically create a
filter and from there we can put out the
details that we require and that is
going to fetch out the details based on
the column storage so that makes data
more structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using Amazon
redshift one is Lya
the other one is Equinox the third one
is the Pfizer which is one of the famous
pharmaceuticals company McDonald's or
one of the burger chains of
rhasta clue and phillips it's an
electronic company so these are one of
the biggest companies that are basically
relying and they are putting their data
on the red chef's data warehouse service
now in another video you'll see the demo
for using the Amazon redshift let's look
into the Amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the Amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we'll be doing is that
we'll be creating an IM role for the
redshift so that the redshift can all
the services and specifically we will be
using the s3 service so the role that we
will be creating will be giving the
permission to read chef to have an
access of an s3 in the read-only format
so in the step 1 what we require will
check the prerequisites and what you
need to have is the AWS credentials if
you don't have that you need to create
your own credentials and you can use
your credit and the debit card and then
in the step 2 we'll proceed with the I
am role for the Amazon redshift
once the role is created will launch a
sample Amazon redshift cluster mentioned
in the step 3 and then we'll assign our
V PC security groups to our cluster now
you can create it in the default view PC
also you can create a default security
groups also otherwise you can customize
the security groups based on your
requirement now to connect to the sample
cluster you need to run the queries and
you can connect to your cluster and run
queries on the AWS management console
query editor which you will find it in
the redshift only or if you use the
query editor you don't have to download
and setup a sequel client application
separately and in the step 6 what you
can do is you can copy the data from the
s3 and upload that in the redshift
because the redshift would have an
access read-only access for the s3 as
that will be created in the I am so
let's see how we can actually use the
redshift on the EWS so I am already
logged in into my account I am in North
Virginia region I will search for a
redshift service and Hale I find Amazon
redshift so just click on it let's wait
for the redshift to come now this is a
redshift dashboard and from here itself
you have to run the cluster so to launch
a cluster you just have to click on this
launch cluster and once the cluster is
created and if you wanted to run queries
you can open query editor or you
basically create queries and access the
data from the redshift so that's what it
was mentioned in the steps also that you
don't require a separate sequel client
application to get the queries run on
the data warehouse now before creating a
cluster we need to create the role so
what we'll do is we'll click on the
services and we'll move to I am role
section so I am rule I can find here
under the security identity and
compliance so just click on the identity
access management and then click on
create roles so let's wait for I am page
to open so here in the I am dashboard
you just have to click on the rules I
already have the role created so what
I'll do is I'll delete this role and
I'll create it separately so just click
on a create role and under the AWS
services you have to select for the
redshift because now the redshift will
be calling the other services and that's
why we are creating the road now which
other services and that the redshift
will be having an axis of s3 why because
we'll be putting up the data on the s3
and that is something which needs to be
uploaded on the redshift
so we'll just search for the redshift
service and we can find it here
so just click on it and then click on a
redshift customizable in the use case
now click on Next permissions and here
in the permissions give the access to
this role assign the permissions to this
role in the form of an s3 read-only
access so you can search share for the
s3 also let's wait for the policies to
come in here at us let's type s3 and
here we can find amazon s3 read-only
access so just click on it and assign
the permissions to this role tags you
can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my red shift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we'll move to red church service and
will create one cluster so click on the
services click on Amazon redshift you
can find that in the history section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of G
B how much David memory you want you can
define it here itself this also gives
you the
formation about the costing on demand is
basically pay as you use so they're
going to charge you 0.5 dollars per hour
for using the two node slices so let's
click on launch this cluster and this
will be a DC 2 dot large kind of an
instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of solid state
drive SSDs which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and the
nodes to are mentioned by default that
means there will be two node slices and
that will be created in a cluster you
can increase them all so let's say if I
put three nodes Rises so it is going to
give us three into point 160 be per node
storage now here you have to define the
master username password for your red
shift cluster and you have to follow the
password instructions so I would put a
password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ASCII characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the rule
that we created recently so in the
available I am rules you just have to
click on my red shift role and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the V PC from default V
PC to your custom APC and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own security groups so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now
let's launch the cluster and here you
can see the red shift cluster is being
created now if you wanted to run queries
on this red shift cluster so you don't
require a separate sequel client you
just have to follow these simple steps
to run a query editor and the query
editor you will find it on the dashboard
so let's click on the cluster and here
you would see that the red shift cluster
would be created with the three nodes in
the US east 1b availability zone so we
have created the red shift
cluster in the ohio region and now what
we'll do is we'll see how we can create
the tables inside the red shift and
we'll see how we can use the copy
command so that we can directly move the
data uploaded on the s3 bucket to the
red shift database tables and then we'll
query the results of a table as well so
how we can do that first
for after creating their check cluster
we have to install the sequel workbench
/j this is not the my sequel which is
managed by Oracle and you can find this
on the Google you can download it from
there
and then you have to connect this client
with the redshift database how you can
do click on file click on connect window
and after connecting a window you have
to paste the URL which is a JDBC driver
this driver
link you can find it on to the AWS
console so if you open up a redshirt
cluster there you would find the JDBC
driver link let's wait for it so this is
our cluster created let's open it and
here you can find this JDBC URL and also
make sure that in the security groups of
a redshift you have the port 5 4 3 9
open for the traffic incoming traffic
you also need to have the Amazon
redshift driver and this is the link
where you can download the driver and
specify the path once you are done with
that you provide the username and the
password that you created while creating
the redshift cluster click on OK so this
connects with the database and now the
database connection is almost completed
now what we will be doing in the sequel
workbench will be first creating the
sales table and then in the sales table
we'll be adding up the entries copied
from the s3 bucket and then move it to
the redshift database and after that we
query the results in the sales table now
whatever the values you are creating in
the table the same values needs to be in
the data file and I have taken up this
sample data file from this link which is
doc start aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticket DB dot zip file
this folder has basically multiple data
files sample data files which you can
actually use it to practice uploading
the data on the redshift cluster so I
have extracted one of the files from
this folder and then I have uploaded
that file in
s3 bucket now we'll move into the s3
bucket let's look for the file that has
been uploaded on the s3 bucket so this
is the bucket sample and sales
underscore tab dot text is the file that
I have uploaded this has the entries
data entries that will be uploaded using
a copy command on to the redshift
cluster now after executing after
putting up the command for rating of the
table then we use a copy command and
copy command we have to define the table
name with table name is sales and we
have to define the path from where the
data would be copied over to the sales
table in the redshift now path is the s3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and it has to look for the data
inside the sales underscore dot dot txt
file also we have to define the role a
RN and that was created previously and
once it is done then the third step is
to query the results inside the sales
table to check whether our data has been
uploaded correctly on the table or not
now what will do is will execute all
these three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it execute
it it's again gives us the error let's
look into the name of the bucket it's
red ship bucket sample so we have two
tees mentioned here right
let's connect with the database again
and now execute it so table se is
created and we got the error the
specified pocket does not exist
Oh redshift bucket sample let's view the
bucket name redshift the bucket sample
let's copy that
put it here connect to the window
connect back to the database right and
now execute it so table sales created
the data in the table has been copied
from the SD bucket to sales underscore
table cortex to the redshift and then
the query of the results the results
from the table has been queried so
that's it with respect to the redshift
perspective and I hope you liked our
video just don't forget to subscribe and
like our channel watch out for our
channel for the upcoming videos
on the aid of distances by funnel thank
you hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here